Gary wants me to put out a ton of
content for free right he wants me to be
super patient he wants me to put all the
money back into the business he wants me
to spend tons of time and hours figuring
[ __ ] out that's actually current which
takes away from leisure time basically I
want you to eat [ __ ] for the next plane
that but had last row so I've been
standing out here for ten minutes
[Music]
sure my pleasure how are you good how
are you good man what's your name
Ben Ben nice to meet you man my pleasure
thank you for watching your contact
thank you brother thank you brother hey
mommy how are you all good stuff from
away how was your new year and all that
hey what are you doing down
okay
all right I gotta go I love you mum what
love you
we're gonna play I like it I don't like
it here we go
I don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it I like it I don't like it I like
it I like it
I don't like it don't like it don't like
it I like it I I love this I don't like
it I love this I don't like it I don't
like I don't like like I like it I like
it I like it
I don't like it I like it I don't like
it I don't like it I don't like it I
don't oh you ready hi hey guys how are
you over here yeah I mean on versus like
the white wall here right here hey guys
it's Gary Vaynerchuk and I'm super fired
up to present business squared all
throughout Australia one day sessions
where we go super deep on how to do
business in the 20/20 world it's nice to
not have d-roc around
I'm kidding the Iraq we love you so much
but you're getting way too much credit
for lemmya Babin swore I'm kidding again
dumb can you put a double kidding there
love you dear Rach we miss you but
here's the important point here's the
important question babbitt do you misty
rock you have a real love/hate with him
right give him very a real rivalry right
and these two characters right here the
audio Oh Mike that was by my tsunami to
be in the mix look at these angles knee
caps talk knee caps I mean just kidding
nobody's nice right he's the best it's
actually good because like it constantly
makes me want to work harder motivations
this could be good episode dropped
episode 293 tweeting comments here
somebody said Gary I don't want to be an
entrepreneur I want to be I want to grow
in corporate America what's your advice
balance right to balance issues if you
work in an organization most of you
conform to what you know your company
wants to hear you say so yet you get
promoted and advance this is absolutely
right and unbelievably wrong how many
people just yes their bosses to death
yeah banner ads yeah television because
they just want to grow and they don't
want to rock the boat
yet when everybody wakes up in six years
and realizes its mobile first video all
the people that were guessing and yes
saying are gonna get fired for saying
the wrong
so you have to find the right balance
playing the internal game of
understanding what the organization
likes and doesn't like while still being
historically correct if you don't
believe in it you have to find
respectful opportunities to tell the
organization hey I don't believe that we
should only be doing direct mail I do
think Facebook ads matter hey I think we
need to have more work-life balance or
we need more hustle what you know it
depends on your org but if there's
anything the org believes in that you
don't believe in you have to find the
right classic kind politically correct
consumable way don't communicate the way
I communicate anything face your way
that's natural to you if you want to win
in a box of an organization the balance
of knowing what it wants they love to
make you say something and then say why
don't you say anything about it and then
they kill you for it so find that
balance that is the winning formula in
an organization it's not to go on this
stage in Utah Salt Lake City gonna rip
their faces off as I like to say and I
know it sounds aggressive but it's
really true and want for them to succeed
honestly a lot of you talking about like
I shoot it straight this that the other
thing I think people get a mixed up it's
not that I want to be cool or Jersey or
I shoot it straight it's that I'm so
desperate for everybody to win because
when other people win it doesn't come at
my expense
so if people could just feel when I feel
everyday even a tenth of it I would feel
so great especially because it impacts
my legacy it means you're talking about
me in a nice way behind my back it's
just all [ __ ] good it's good I'm good
on good and the reality is people that
sell bad and are negative they're loud
and charismatic normally I'm just a good
soldier that's loud and charismatic and
that's why we're a people space as
always that's why i suffocate [ __ ]
that's why I want you to win
[Applause]
the one thing that combines every person
in this room the one thing that we are
all aligned with the one thing that
everybody on YouTube right there is
watching right now is aligned with is
that everybody here has to find the
attention before they tell me how great
their product of services what can I
focus on what can bring the most value
to the thousands instead of the specific
needs that everybody wants and the one
thing for me that I'm really focused on
these days is fear and excuses right if
you're gonna follow the things I believe
in you have to close your eyes for the
next five to ten years and not give a
[ __ ] about anything that happened you
have to basically take a step back and
say okay Gary wants me to put out a ton
of content for free he wants me to be
super patient he wants me to put all the
money back into the business he wants me
to spend tons of time and hours figuring
[ __ ] out that's actually current which
takes away from leisure time basically I
want you to eat [ __ ] for the next second
hour people in here tired of doing the
same dumb [ __ ] over and over in some
slight different variation with some
[ __ ] charismatic person at the top
and not having it [ __ ] work aren't
you [ __ ] tired
how about eating [ __ ] instead
thank you
[Applause]
I saw it I saw it we are making excuses
and we do it every day because it feels
a lot better to [ __ ] on somebody else
then look at yourself and [ __ ] on
yourself I don't look at anybody outside
no [ __ ] idea what you guys are up to
I [ __ ] on myself every day I critique
everything I do everything is my fault
period end of story somebody hits me
with a [ __ ] car tomorrow I'm like
[ __ ] I shouldn't have left the house
that early you get into that [ __ ]
mindset I promise you [ __ ] changes hello
[Applause]
thank you
you need to [ __ ] suffocate your
[ __ ] you're at this conference that
means we need to suffocate your [ __ ]
period you either need to figure out
who's holding you back and their
judgment and go to them I want you to
get out of this [ __ ] conference go to
your car call your mom and say [ __ ] you
if she's the person that is suppressing
you because she's miserable and misery
loves company I mean that's serious with
you
now everybody's favorite part of every
daily be airport Gary I'm a little bit
worried right now huh nope yeah regret
scares the [ __ ] out of me regret is the
fuel besides gratitude that drives my
life you will see people and they will
tell you things about the things they
they do and the silliness to why they
didn't do it and they're running out of
time do you sit in this room and you
have time you have time it's your 70 80
90 of times in 15 you've time but to sit
and list all the reasons you can't it's
just here's how I look at it if anybody
that looks like you has ever done it
then you can - just laying it back in
New York you know that normal everyday
road trip to Salt Lake City and back
that Salt Lake City community in a way
feel phenomenal just engaged with a ton
of you on Instagram and snap feeling
invigorated by the [ __ ] game when you
love it it's hard to be lazy when you
love it it's hard to be lazy
[Music]
you know there's no like and here's the
[ __ ] plan there's no care of the
[ __ ] band and [ __ ] that